Happy New Year everybody it's a brand
new year to do a whole bunch of things
that you perhaps have always wanted to
do or you could just wrap up in a
blanket because it's disastrously cold
outside that's what I'm doing right now
anyway
last year I started a new tradition I
wanted to talk about films that I
thought perhaps passed under people's
radars or films that I liked more than
critics or people and this year we're
gonna do that again starting with a
whole bunch of films that I found very
underrated these are gonna be films that
I thought were at least fine - really
good that critics or audiences didn't
really appreciate and then after I get
through all these we'll talk about films
that I thought were overlooked in 2017
so starting off the underrated list is
Roman Jay Israel Esquire I saw this film
in a gigantic blitz of holiday movies
and it was one of those that I just
didn't get around to reviewing but I
thought Denzel was terrific in this
movie it got a lot of bad press out of
TIF and they went into the editing room
and made a whole new cut of the film and
that's the cut that we saw in theaters
if you didn't see it at TIFF and so it's
a little tough to understand where
critics fall on this one because the
initial reviews that went on Rotten
Tomatoes were for that TIFF screening
but the film was quickly re-edited and
so I thought this film was mostly pretty
good the first half I really enjoyed the
last half loses its way a little bit
after Roman makes this decision and then
he goes on this vacation but Denzel made
this movie incredibly watchable the
Meyerowitz stories was written and
directed by Noah Baumbach and Stardust
and Hoffman and Adam Sandler and Ben
Stiller and Emma Thompson and a lot of
really talented people and critics
really seemed to like it and people
seemed to like it too but it is getting
absolutely no Oscar buzz and I think it
should for writing in particular and I
hope that it could get a nom but it
probably won't I found this film really
realistic and extremely entertaining and
it was one of my favorite written films
of the year that could be because it was
on Netflix that it's not getting a lot
of buzz and the Oscars they're still
kind of butting heads with the whole
streaming thing we'll see how that works
out in the future going in
style was by no means a great film but I
liked it considerably more than critics
did and a lot of that has to do with the
fact that it's Morgan Freeman Michael
Caine and Alan Arkin in the same movie
acting like old curmudgeons
and that's just very entertaining Guy
Ritchie's King Arthur was absolutely
blasted by critics for a while this year
it was referred to as the bomb of the
year everyone wanted to trash on it at
least critics did audiences however and
myself I think for the most part found
the film fine I thought the film was
actually pretty entertaining and a lot
of that had to do with Charlie Hunnam
who I really liked as this character Guy
Ritchie had a lot of good action
sequences to the film has a lot of
narrative and structure problems though
and I didn't shy away from talking about
that in my review but I missed the film
because I was shooting my short film
when it came out and I saw it late so I
went in thinking this is gonna be a
disaster horrible and I was like this is
fine what's the big deal why is everyone
so angry about King Arthur it didn't
make sense to me
alien covenant got quite a bit of hate
and quite a bit of love but it has been
very divisive for fans overall I think
most fans were disappointed with the
movie and if you were to ask me if I was
disappointed by alien covenant the
answer would be yes I was I really loved
Prometheus and I obviously think alien
and aliens are terrific films so when it
came to alien covenant the fact that I
walked out thinking that was pretty good
that was fine it was good that was
disappointing to me but the venomous
hate that it's gotten I don't think is
entirely deserved I think the film has a
lot of really interesting and compelling
storylines and just Michael Fassbender
alone and his work with David and Walter
make this film we're seeing a cure for
wellness was directed by Gore Verbinski
and I found this film extremely
challenging in a very good way it was
insane and so weird and I really enjoyed
it it was beautifully shot as well in
Dane DeHaan gave one of his best
performances however it is one of those
movies when you leave it you're like
okay that was either incredibly
pretentious or awful or both and I loved
it for both of those reasons I really
enjoyed watching this movie
ghost in the shell' was very polarizing
for fans and polarizing for critics this
film wasn't hated like say Dragonball
Evolution or The Last Airbender but it
did get mostly negative reviews and some
people have called a trash some people
think it's really underrated including
myself I thought this was a visually
stunning movie that yes borrows quite a
bit from other science fiction just like
a lot of other science fiction borrowed
from Mamoru Oshii his original ghost in
the show so to adapt it as faithfully as
they did I was really happy I thought it
was a beautifully directed movie and
with amazing action sequences and good
performances and a great score as well
I'm not exactly sure what critics
expected going into the lego ninjago
movie because obviously it's not as
popular of a franchise as say Batman is
the lego movie was much better and much
more subversive but a lot of people seem
to focus on this film as being that
first just franchise comedy movie for
kids but I thought the humor was
actually pretty satirical and most of
the time really well-done the animation
was also beautiful it's definitely the
worst of the three without a doubt but I
don't think it's as bad as critics said
sleepless starring Jamie Foxx was a
movie last January that I didn't love I
wouldn't even say it's great but I did
find the movie fairly watchable and
actually quite entertaining as an action
film especially when you pile it around
a bunch of trash Sleepless stood out to
me as a film that did what it wanted to
do it was an action movie in one
location for the most part with fairly
competent performances it felt like a
mishmash of a lot of other things and it
had some really silly dialogue Phoenix
forgotten is a movie that is extremely
easy to hate on it's a found footage
horror movie that no one really saw it
has a lot of continuity errors when it
comes to time character zone things that
weren't even released in 1997 when this
film takes place but I thought it was
actually pretty effective and some of
that does have to do with the fact that
I do have an interest in the paranormal
and I like investigating things like
that like hauntings or aliens or strange
sightings and that always has had sort
of a weird
I've had like a morbid curiosity about
that and so I might be a little biased
towards liking this film but I thought
it was actually fairly well directed and
had some good performances in it
Martin Campbell's new film the foreigner
starring Jackie Chan may have been miss
marketed as a film that was mostly an
action movie but Martin Campbell makes
films that are a little more deeper than
that usually and I thought this was one
of Jackie Chan's best performances most
people seem to enjoy the foreigner but
critics were kind of mixed on it I
thought it was very well directed I
thought Pierce Brosnan did some of his
best work ever as well as Jackie Chan
and the action sequences that were there
surrounded by a very complex political
story riveted me okay we're gonna get
into the overlooked films of 2017 now
these are films I saw that I really
appreciated but that perhaps didn't do
too much of the box office or people
never really talked about at all
starting with Brad's status Ben Stiller
gave the performance of his career with
this movie Mike White wrote and directed
it and I found it very touching it was
the exact type of movie I wanted to see
when I went to the theater to see it the
performances were all really strong and
the emotional bond between Stiller and
his son in the film was really sweet the
devil's candy was the second film Sean
Byrne made after the loved ones which is
also very good this horror film
surprised the out of me it has an
incredible performance by ethan embry a
very dark story and one that I've never
seen told in this way from the
perspective they chose to tell it and
probably not too many of you actually
saw it even though I gave it a pretty
strong review I know amongst like the
indie circuit of horror fans a lot of
people talk about this movie but
mainstream audiences missed this one
entirely to the bone was a Netflix film
that gave us Lily Collins best
performance and one of Keanu Reeves best
it was a film about a woman who suffers
from anorexia she goes to a house that's
sort of like this therapeutic
environment with other people who are
also suffering from similar things and I
found it very uplifting and I think not
too many people saw it personal shopper
starring Kristen Stewart was not a ghost
movie not a haunting movie as it
advertised that pissed a lot of
mainstream audiences off this film
reminded me of the witch not in the way
it was executed they're completely
different movies but their response from
the public was very similar because the
witch was marketed as this horrifying
terrifying you know this this mainstream
horror movie and it was very artsy and
very good personal shopper is similar
this is not a movie about some scary
haunted house it's about a woman trying
to reconnect with a loved one and I
thought it was very powerful and Stewart
was incredible in the movie gifted was
one of two Marc Webb films last year and
this one started Chris Evans and this
was really good it's definitely Marc
Webb's best film since 500 days of
summer I didn't see his second film last
year the only living boy in New York or
whatever it was called I heard that one
wasn't too good I haven't seen it so I
can't really comment on that but gifted
had two really excellent performances in
Chris Evans and the young girl who also
is in hi Tanya which is kind of cool so
she's getting more work and she deserves
it because she was incredible I think
her name is McKenna grace Meghan levy
starring kate mara was terrific nobody's
talking about this movie it has some
really good performances it has a very
very sweet story about a bond with a
German Shepherd and I thought it was
awesome I'm really surprised that
critics seem to like it
people seem to think it's fine too but
no one's talking about it I don't really
understand why is it because people are
afraid to watch a movie where there's a
dog in violent and terrifying situations
I don't know it's really good go see it
1922 features one of the best
performances of last year that of Thomas
Jane this is a Stephen King adaptation
that's on Netflix and it was chilling I
actually got to see okiya in theaters
before it went to Netflix there was a
screening and I got to see it early I
don't remember why I didn't review it I
think I had a whole bunch of other
videos that week and it just ended up
getting shuffled to the bottom of the
pile and I wish that it didn't because
it was quite good and this is from the
director of snowpiercer which I loved he
has some really terrific sequences in
this film the only thing that didn't
really work for me was
didn't actually feel the bond that much
between the young girl and okhta which
is very important but I loved how
different this film was helmed how
unique it felt Maudie starring sally
hawkins and ethan hawke had some really
terrific performances ethan hawke was
kind of scary for a while in the film he
plays a very broken character who is
abusive and very difficult to live with
but sally hawkins between mati and the
shape of water if she doesn't receive
some kind of nomination for the Oscars
this year it's there's gonna be riots
because she deserves it super dark times
tells the story of some kids who
accidentally do something pretty bad and
then have to cover it up for a while and
this film captured the 90s unlike any
other film I've seen in years
I authenticate into a passageway into
the 90s it was also just as the title
might suggest very dark and they did a
great job with the character work in
particular in this movie Briggs bbear
may have been the most unique film of
last year it has a story I don't want to
spoil it you know because I actually
went in not knowing anything about it I
didn't know what the plot was I just
knew that Mark Hamill was in it and it
looked weird and cool it is both of
those things and Hamill is very good in
the film just just go see it it's weird
it's really weird you'll you'll probably
like it I talked about a ghost story in
my best of the year video and I've
recommended it enough it's really damn
great and you should see it it was one
of the most emotional experiences I had
at the theater last year and I wish that
the Oscars were talking about it it's so
good the killing of a sacred deer yes I
did see this film and I did not get a
chance to review it because it fell into
that hole like I just saw 18 films in a
row at the end of December and this is
one of them and I have to pick a few of
them to review this is a very
challenging movie and I don't even know
if I a hundred percent liked it because
it's just so it's like what I left the
theater actually saying like what the
hell but something about the
performances and the camerawork in the
audacity of the film I
can't help I recommend so if you get a
chance to see it see it similar to
killing a sacred deer I was very divided
on hit comes at night I didn't even
really like the film overall I would say
I lean towards not really appreciating
it because it just didn't 100% work for
me but I did see it twice in one weekend
and it made me want to analyze it so
there's something to be said there and I
think film fans should seek this one out
and figure out where you stand on it
because it's worth seeing a silent voice
was an amazing anime film I saw last
year that was very very touching and
very powerful that had a relevant story
that I think a lot of young kids today
should see professor Marston and the
Wonder Woman is a film that like no
one's talking about it was damn good
incredible performances and a very very
timely story and lastly Columbus a
gorgeously directed movie with great
work from John Cho and Haley Lou
Richardson who both give career best
performances it was directed by Cogan
nada a man mostly known for online video
essays so that's awesome
I mean that's like you go man represent
cuz I mean that's that just gives me
hope you know and I thought the film was
incredibly well done guys those are some
of my most favorite underrated and
overlooked films this year what are some
of yours I'm curious to know and stay
tuned soon for a review of 12 Angry Men
if you guys saw on Twitter my new year's
resolution was to review one pre-1970s
film a month all year because I want to
give more attention to films of the
Golden Age era of Hollywood I don't
think there's enough of that on YouTube
there's a lot of 80s and 90s talk we
need to talk about some really great
films and we're gonna do that this year
12 Angry Men is the first one I'm gonna
talk about that very soon guys you are
the best thank you very much for
watching as always if you liked this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]